hey what is up everybody it's animak
here
for anime uproar and today i will be
ranking the
top 10 strongest characters who have
shown to be able to use
more than one quirk whether it's
stealing quirks
mimicking quirks or imprinting multiple
quirks on a single person
the boku no hero series has given us a
bunch of extremely powerful characters
who can use
multiple quirks and as you might imagine
they are some of the strongest
characters in the entire series
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you are new
to anime outpour or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a ton of our videos even if you
are subscribed
it's just how youtube works big shout
out to our anime opera
patrons who make long videos like this
one possible
i will talk more about patreon at the
end of the video but first
please be advised that this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
i will be referencing all of the
available information in the manga so
please proceed with
caution you have been warned just a
heads up even though the quirk one for
all was created by combining two
separate quirks
i will not be treating one for all
itself as two quirks
in this video one for all became the
quirk it is today
only after two separate quirks had
already combined
so because of that i'm treating one for
all as a single quirk and someone who
only used one for all like for example
all might will not be included
in this list however anyone who was able
to use one for all
and another separate quirk at the same
time is fair game
at number 10 we have the usj
nomu the first multiple quirk user that
we got to see up close
is the monstrous nomu that appeared
alongside the league of villains during
the usj
arc this nomu was formerly a normal
person who was experimented on by all
for one
and dr ujjiko and whose genes were
spliced with the genes of multiple
different people
in order to create an obedient fighting
machine
this nomu is essentially a mindless
slave whose only purpose in life is to
follow shigaraki's orders without
question but even though he lacks
intelligence and free will
the usg nomu is still extremely powerful
and
ruthless as a result of the
experimentation conducted on him by
ujico and all for one
this nomu is able to use two incredibly
strong quirks
shock absorption and super regeneration
shock absorption allows him to absorb
the force of all attacks that come his
way
although there is a limit to how much
damage he can take
super regeneration allows him to recover
almost instantly from even the most
severe
physical attacks this nomu was designed
with the specific intention of defeating
all might
and it demonstrated unbelievable speed
and strength
as it went toe to toe with all might
himself and
all might was at the time still the
number one pro hero
although all might ultimately succeeded
in defeating the snomo he was forced to
put in a lot of effort
to take the monster down and it was
clear that the other pro heroes like
aizawa
didn't stand a chance against this nomu
that said this
nomu is not the strongest nomu that all
for one anujiko would ultimately create
and even though he was a formidable
challenge for all might at this point in
the story
all might was far from his prime for
this reason the usg nomu comes in at
number 10
on our list at number nine we have
himiko
toga when we first found out about
togasquirk
there was no indication that she had the
ability to use multiple quirks
toga's quirk called transform allowed
her to physically transform herself into
another person
if she is able to consume enough of that
person's blood she could mimic
all of the physical details of that
person's appearance and she could mimic
their voice
but that was the extent of her abilities
well
she could also briefly make herself
practically invisible
but that was it transform was certainly
a useful quirk
especially when it came to stealth
operations like spying going undercover
and all that kind of stuff
but it was never a strong offensive
quirk and it required a large amount
of blood to work so it wasn't the
easiest quirk to activate
nevertheless in chapter 226 when toga is
injured and on the brink of death she
suddenly experiences
a quirk awakening at this point
toga suddenly becomes capable of not
only transforming into someone
physically but she also learns to
actually use that person's
quirk toga is able to transform into
ochaco
and use ochako's quirk zero gravity
what's more she is able to use the quirk
very effectively against a large number
of enemies
at the same time it seems that after the
evolution of her quirk
toga is able to copy and use the quirk
of someone that she has transformed into
as long as she has seen the quirk in
action and knows how it works
needless to say while the ability to
change her physical appearance into
someone else was useful for spying and
intel gathering
the power to also copy that person's
quirk changes the game completely
as long as toga consumes enough blood
from multiple people she is able to
transform
into those people at will and she can
use her awakened quirk to also mimic
their quirks in battle imagine if she
kept some of twice's blood stashed away
somewhere
now imagine if toga ends up using sad
man's parade
toga is a total wild card in boku no
hero
and after the awakening of her quirk we
simply cannot
underestimate her but at the same time
the requirements for toga to use her
quirk can be extremely challenging to
meet
and that is why i can't rank her higher
than number nine
on this list at number eight we have
nana shimura nana was the seventh user
of one for all
and since we know that one for all is an
accumulation type quirk
we know that it must have already been
quite strong by this point
one for all was already possessed by six
users prior to being inherited by nana
meaning that it must have accumulated a
lot of power over the course of
multiple decades we know how insanely
strong
all might was and nana was the user just
before him
and she was also his mentor so it's safe
to assume that she was incredibly strong
as well
on top of one for all nana also had a
second quirk
the original quirk that she was born
with which is float
float allows the user to levitate
through the air
so essentially nana could use one for
all and also fly
while doing it although we know that she
was not strong enough to defeat
all for one nana definitely deserves a
spot
on this list all might would not have
become the legendary hero that he is
today
if nana hadn't been such an extremely
strong and effective mentor
at number seven we have daigoro banjo
daigorobanjo was another former one for
all user
and the fifth user to be precise i chose
to include bonjour
on this list because i think that his
original quirk black whip
works extremely well in combination with
one for all
and we've already seen that first hand
after deck unlocks black whip and then
learns to use it with one for all
since daigo banjo is the fifth user one
for all itself
would have been fairly strong by this
point although not as strong
as it would become later but because
black whip
is such a powerful and versatile quirk i
decided to put bonjour
ahead of nana while her second quirk
float
is certainly very useful i think black
whip could be even more useful
in combination with one for all that is
just my personal opinion of course and
it is totally possible that nana was
stronger than bonjour but i just think
that someone who has had an entire
lifetime to master black whip
would be able to do so much with it from
attacking and restraining opponents to
defending and invading attacks to
climbing buildings to launching yourself
into the air
there is just so much that black whip
can do and
that is why banjo is at number seven on
our list at number six we have the high
end nomu the high-end nomu are on a
completely different level from all the
other nomu
in many ways they are much much stronger
they don't just follow orders they are
actually strategic and intelligent
and on top of that they are able to use
as many as six
different quirks now it is difficult to
single out just one high in nomu as
being the strongest
because what we've seen from them so far
has been quite limited
hood is the high-end nomu that we got to
see in action most
thoroughly during the battle against
endeavour and hawks
but it is quite possible that some of
the other high-end such as the female
nomu
are actually stronger than hood the
female nomu
also known as woman was released by
uchiko along with four other hai and
nomu
at a time of emergency if these nomu had
stayed in their tubes for a longer
period of time they might have emerged
even stronger moreover the female nomu
showed more intelligence
and more strategic prowess than hood in
my opinion so it is quite possible that
she would have been able to defeat
hood but the female nomu's power is hard
to scale
because we only saw her during one
battle which involved multiple nomu and
multiple heroes all going at each other
that said even if we just go by hood's
battle against endeavor and hawks
it is clear that a high-end like hood
definitely belongs
on this list hood was so strong that he
was able to tear down the sides of
entire buildings
in a single strike and endeavour the
current
number one pro hero acknowledged that
hood was stronger
than him the only reason why endeavour
was able to come out on top at the end
is because he had the help and support
of the current number 2 pro hero
hawks so it was only the combined
strength of the two strongest pro heroes
that finally brought
hood down at number five we have the
incredibly powerful
hero waifu turned villain waifu turned
maybe hero waifu again
lady nagant lady nagant is a former hero
who was imprisoned inside tartarus
after killing the president of the hero
public safety commission
she escaped tartarus after all for one's
big prison break
and she is so strong that hawks warned
deku to immediately run away
if he ever meets her meaning that deku
should not even try to fight against her
because
she is just too strong now to be fair
hawks isn't aware of the full extent of
deku's power
and deck who keeps getting stronger and
stronger with each passing chapter
but the fact that hawks issued this type
of warning to deku before deku even met
lady nagant tells us just how notorious
and powerful she is considered to be a
top tier assassin
lady nagan's reputation even impressed
all for one
and he recruited her to capture deku for
him she is the best long-range fighter
in all of japan maybe even in the world
and even snipe admits that he can't hold
a candle to lady nagant
her original quirk is called rifle and
it allows her to generate
a large long-range rifle from her right
elbow
she can also extend a piece of flesh
from that rifle
up to her eye and use it as a scope
using strands of her hair
lady nagant can create all different
types of bullets that she can then place
into the rifle and fire off at a range
of up to 3 kilometers
this seems to be the best long range
quirk in the mha world
and thanks to her special bullets that
she can make herself
lady nagant can do absolutely crazy
things like make her bullets curve
around buildings
and hit seemingly impossible targets
lady nagant also possesses a second
quirk that was given to her by all for
one
in order to help her complete her
mission to capture deku
this quirk is air walk which allows the
user to levitate through the air
as you can imagine being the world's
greatest long distance shooter and then
being able to fly through the air and
get a bird's eye view
on your opponent whenever you want is a
killer combination
and while i don't agree with hawks that
deku must run away from lady nagant
because she is too strong for him i
think that deku has proven otherwise
especially as he continues to master his
new quirks
i do think the lady nagant definitely
belongs in the top 5
strongest multiple quirk users in mha
at number four is none other than
deku as the ninth and current one for
all user
deco has the advantage of using the
quirk now that it is at its strongest
ever in fact deku inherited the quirk at
a crucial moment
in its evolution and as a result he is
able to manifest the original quirks of
all of the previous one for all users
in addition to being able to use one for
all itself and if that
wasn't enough all the additional quirks
that deku gets to unlock are even
stronger now than they were when they
were being used by their original users
and this is because a one for all's
growing strength has made these
additional quirks
even stronger as of the making of this
video deku has unlocked
black whip float danger sense smoke
screen
and fog in and not only has deku
unlocked these quirks but he has already
shown a truly impressive ability to
combine the different quirks in
extremely effective ways
in battle deku is learning quickly and
getting stronger with
each passing chapter and i'm sure that
eventually he will be able to climb his
way to the very top
of this list but for now he remains at
number
4. at number 3 we have
gigantomachia gigantomachia
is all for one's former bodyguard and
one of the strongest characters
in the entire series he is fiercely
loyal to his master
all for one and to his master's
successor tomura shigaraki
as his name suggests gigantomachia can
increase his size until he becomes a
genuine
giant and in this gigantic state
he can take down entire mountains and
entire city blocks
on his own on top of having insane and
utterly superhuman power
speed and stamina gigantomachia also has
at least
seven different quirks gigantomachia's
only known weakness is that he can
hardly
think for himself he requires orders
from his master
in order to carry out a task and the
only known task that he can accomplish
without being ordered to
is to come protect his master along with
being able to become
gigantic he can also completely block
out pain
he can convert his morale into stamina
he can enhance his senses
he can harden his muscles and he can
grow giant claws from his hands
and probably a lot more during the epic
war arc
it took literally dozens of heroes and
hero students to take
this man down and even then all they
could do is sedate him
he also managed to kill multiple pro
heroes in the process
while injuring many many others
gigantomachia's biggest weakness
is that he doesn't really have a will of
his own and unless he gets those direct
orders from his master or unless he
believes that he is acting to protect
his master
he isn't really a threat but at the same
time
when he does have the proper motivation
gigantomachia is a force of nature
he is a walking natural disaster and he
is
nearly unstoppable at number 2 we have
all for one all for one is the greatest
villain in the history of japan
and he is an absolutely ruthless
mastermind with an incredibly
overpowered quirk
all for one the quirk allows its user to
steal the quirks of others
and then use those quirks himself and
this includes combining multiple quirks
inside one person to create extremely
effective
offensive and defensive techniques all
for one can combine
multiple stolen quirks in order to
create more powerful super quirks that
would never have occurred
naturally and he was even able to slow
down the aging process
thanks to a quirk he copied from dr
ujiko all for one is able to forcibly
activate the quirks of others
and he can also transfer stolen quirks
into other people
allowing him to create his own army of
villains with super powered combo quirks
gigantomachia is of course one of all
for one's creations
as are the nomu all for one has
incredible intelligence
generations of experience and a
countless number of quirks
at his disposal not to mention the army
of multiple quirk users that he himself
is able to create
this makes him one of the strongest
characters in the entire series and the
second strongest multiple quirk user
in boku no hero now before we get into
the strongest multiple quark user
here are some honorable mentions first
up we have the third
one for all user i think that his
original quirk
fojin is such a good companion quirk to
one for all
fojin is basically a major buff for one
for all itself
you can use fojin to make your one for
all based attacks
much stronger and faster but with that
said
one for all itself was nowhere near as
strong back then
as it is now so that is why the third
user is an honorable mention
rather than being on the list himself
the same goes for all of the other
one for all users they were all strong
and they all deserve an honorable
mention
but i don't think that they quite make
the list based on their original quirks
and based on the strength of one for all
at the time i also want to give a quick
shout out to some of the villains from
the first two
mha movies including wolfram 9
and chimera who all used more than one
quirk
i chose not to include them on this list
not because they aren't strong enough to
be here
but because it is basically impossible
to power scale them in any meaningful
way
the movies are not really canon at least
not fully
and while there are some references to
characters from the movies in the actual
manga
there are also some clear
inconsistencies which make it impossible
to accurately compare the movie villains
to the canonical characters
finally i'd like to give an honorable
mention to shoto todoroki i didn't
include him on the list because he
technically has only one quirk
but that quirk consists of two
completely different powers that can be
used
separately so you could definitely make
an argument for shoto being a multiple
quirk user
also i guess monoma has potential but he
has a long way to go
and the absolutely strongest multiple
quirk user
at this point in the story is the
monster that is
awakened shigaraki in my opinion
shigaraki started out as a pretty
mediocre villain early on in the story
but over 300 chapters later he has
become an entirely different
person he is so much stronger now that
he was at the beginning that he is
essentially a totally different villain
don't get me wrong shigaraki has always
been very intelligent and
analytical and he's always had an
overwhelming hatred for the hero society
because of what he went through as a
child
this hatred imbued shigaraki with
incredible willpower
he will stop at nothing to destroy the
hero society
and this exceptional willpower is one of
the main reasons why
all for one took such a great interest
in shigaraki in the first place
after decades of trying to figure out a
way to steal one for all
all for one came to the conclusion that
one for all can in fact
be stolen but it can only be stolen by
someone with overpowering hatred
and unfathomable willpower someone who
can subdue the vestiges of the former
one for all users
and force the quirk to bend to his will
all for one believes that shigaraki is
the one who can make
this happen as i mentioned shigaraki has
undergone a massive transformation
over the past few arcs of the story a
transformation that is both physical
and psychological first he was able to
awaken the true power of his
quirk decay when we first meet him
shigaraki is able to only disintegrate
something that he touches with all five
of his fingers
and it took some time for that
disintegration to actually run its
course
but after his quirk awakened to its true
power
the decaying became instantaneous and it
could also spread beyond the person or
object that shigaraki was actually
touching directly the decay could now
spread to multiple enemies and destroy
them all at once and the quirk's ability
was further boosted after shigeraki
underwent ujjiko's body modifying
procedure
the procedure made shigaraki much
stronger physically and it also made him
capable of decaying
practically a third of an entire city
with one attack
shigaraki now also has more control of
his decay and he can seemingly decide
what he wants decayed and one he wants
spared
ujico's procedure has also drastically
increased shigaraki's speed and stamina
which is why he is now in a completely
different level of power than he was
before
but this is a list about multiple quirk
users
and ujiku's procedure had another
important effect it
transferred the original version of the
quirk all for one
on to shigaraki along with a bunch of
other quirks that the villain all for
one had stolen in the past
these quirks include super regeneration
ragdoll's former quirk
surge air cannon radio waves that red
tendril quirk known as rivet stab
and who knows how many more and despite
being a newly minted multiple quirk user
shigaraki has already demonstrated an
incredible ability to use these quirks
together
in order to fight multiple top tier
heroes on his own
to be fair fujiku's procedure was
interrupted before it could be completed
so the new shigaraki is not actually as
strong as he could have been
but he is still almost certainly the
strongest character
at this point in the story he can
destroy large
chunks of a city with a single attack he
can take on a large number of top tier
pro heroes
on his own and he has the potential to
become even stronger
if the villains can figure out a way to
complete ujico's procedure
there are several reasons why i believe
that shigaraki is even
stronger than all for one in his prime
this includes shigaraki's newly awakened
decay quirk which all for one did not
possess
it also includes the super regeneration
quirk which all for one only came across
after he was already permanently injured
by almighty
on top of that the procedure that ujico
conducted on shigaraki is far more
advanced than anything he could have
done for all for one back in all for
one's prime
and of course shigaraki's hatred and
willpower are presumably even greater
than all for once
because as we know all for one never
could find a way to steal one for all
himself
but he believes that shigaraki will be
able to do it now it is important to
mention that all for one's plan
is to perfect chicago's body and then
take it over from the inside
using all for one's work factor which
somehow retains
his own consciousness within it but
whether this plan succeeds or not
shigaraki is at this moment the
strongest multiple quirk user in the
story
and almost certainly the strongest
character in the story period
now let me know what you guys think do
you agree with this list
and if not no hard feelings just let me
know in the comments what your own list
would look like
if you enjoyed this pocono hero video
and you want to see more in the future
just leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter
and instagram at animeopror a big thank
you to all of our anime upper patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to the absolute mad
lad and biggest lifetime donator
alpha sigma disciple of lord twego
himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa aldratal
dr cortman the toasted chi emperor otaku
spidey life chanel tungsten tarkis
faked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red haired raven on hell
crews anatoly kasatsuki very gucci
alicia octor bonnie park sino camino
water joanne garcia ted no ted fat boy
games
corey mcgowan metal mama deadly saint
and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you